in Hollywood there are more actors than
parts when you're trying to get a career
going rejection is par for the course
still it's hard to believe some of these
failed auditions that cost huge actors
some legendary roles Robert DeNiro the
Godfather sure he won Best Supporting
Actor for playing young Vito Corleone in
The Godfather Part 2
but Robert De Niro actually auditioned
for the part of Sonny in the first
father movies brains James Caan got it
but that's okay Sonny was a chump Vito
was a legend Seth Rogen and Bob Odenkirk
the office between Freaks and Geeks
cancellation in 2000 and the 40 year old
virgin in 2005 Seth Rogen had a bit of a
dry spell during that period he
auditioned for the role of Dwight on the
office urine is sterile you know what if
you're in the field you can clean the
man's wound by taking a whiz on Rainn
Wilson got the part and Rogen went on to
become an a-list actor and writer
meanwhile Bob Odenkirk was already a
comedy legend when he auditions at the
lead role of Michael Scott we play hard
and we work hard sometimes we probably
play hard when we should be working hard
but that's probably my fault but
firemen he lost a Steve Carell that's
known at the time as a correspondent on
The Daily Show
Odenkirk must have been pretty close
because he gets started in the final
season as an eerily Michael Scott ask
boss at an office where Pam lands an
interview on the horrible boss around
here
but please don't hire a Jamie Foxx to
kill me Jengo I don't agree with the use
of the n-word in that movie it's too
soon
Scarlett Johansson Jumanji this future
Avengers started as a child star her
first big screen role came when she was
just 9 in the 1994 comedy north
the following year ScarJo missed out on
Jumanji to Kirsten Dunst would you
forget about the stupid game now close
it up and put it away Josh Hutcherson
amazing spider-man every young actor
between 18 and 30 probably had a shot at
Peter Parker and his agile alter ego
Josh Hutcherson had just filmed his
first Hunger Games when he showed up for
this audition one franchise would have
to do despite Hutcherson solid screen
tests for 2012's amazing spider-man
Andrew Garfield wore the web's winneth
Paltrow Jurassic Park Steven Spielberg
cast Paltrow in a bit part in hook 2
years later he got her an audition for
his surefire dinosaur blockbuster or
maybe maybe it's just a ritual behavior
species-specific behavior then serves to
identify them to one another that maybe
he doesn't have any broader meaning but
the future Oscar winner apparently just
wasn't as good as Laura Dern Brad Pitt
backdraft hansoms check talented check
but in 1991 casting directors hadn't
seen Brad Pitt's full potential yet he
auditioned for backdraft but instead
they went with the Brad Pitt of 1991
Billy Baldwin Jeremy Sisto Titanic
Jeremy Sisto was hot off his appearance
as Elton in clueless when he auditioned
for Titanic today it's impossible to
imagine anyone but Leonardo DiCaprio
yelling about being king of the world in
the James Cameron blockbuster but it's
still fascinating to watch a screen test
with Kate Winslet
thank you a few years after whipping on
this roll cystal landed the gig on Six
Feet Under and went on to star in Law &
Order Suburgatory and plenty more Kurt
Russell Star Wars
unfortunately for Kurt Russell he
auditioned for the soon-to-be iconic
role of Han Solo against Harrison Ford
the only actor of the era who was more
effortlessly cool than Kurt Russell I
was only paid to bring you here and now
you're here so I'll just take my other
five thousand and you're on your own
it's okay Harrison Ford never could have
handled Snake Plissken or Jack Burton
Tom Selleck Raiders of the Lost Ark it's
the most famous Hollywood what if Tom
Selleck was offered the role of Indiana
Jones but had to refuse because he was
stuck filming magnum p.i Harrison Ford
strikes again look I did what I did I
don't expect you to be happy about it
but maybe it can do us both some good
but oh what could have been Indiana
Jones would have had a killer mustache
for example thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which actor you would have rather
seen get the part
[Music]